hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters like that
one and we I've got a brown daemon key
for the brown daemon door let me try the
upstairs one first but some goodies I am
happy that I've been collecting goodies
Oh Jill it's you is you give me
entrepreneurially get on the railing
come here
come at me bro come here maybe I don't
even know what's so dangerous about you
you're all tied down you're in a
wheelchair
chained up come at me come at me bro
come on what are you doing you scared
I'd be scared too
I'm pretty scary alright fine cuz
sidestep whoa side ha damn it oh you
bleed on me that's how you hurt me
socked up sidestep dammit
sidestep that's creepy
sidestep miss me sidestep it's me again
med combat save sure yeah yeah
kiyah stuck on that sucker
let's try this ah ah there we go all the
door closed here I open the door for you
buddy ah too close don't even try it
don't even try it don't even try ah damn
it that's my own stupid yo take that one
come back here come here come here come
here
ah yeah there we go and back under fifty
health but whatever do that ah god damn
it oh good oh oh
scare the crap outta me uh I mean no I
was totally ready for him and ginger
boom ya got ya I don't out like
invisible monsters I have to revolve
around left that's not so bad
I had 12 come in with yes back up on
health I like it I like it much all
right here we go what's down here
oh well wait whoa whoa I need to go
downstairs hey yeah I need to check and
see what's oh come on don't be like that
yeah I gotta check what's downstairs
first if that's the way out
oh no wait that's the only thing oh I
came in through the downstairs one what
am I thinking I'm an idiot I'm an idiot
I'm big stupid hello
I know moths you're on this yeah I climb
this yes again nice touch
don't like this
I don't like much in this game but in
this side oh come on I see them out
there oh I gotta jump down bull honkey
Oh fine I don't think I have enough room
to run me yeah there's enough room to
run around
okay holy crap there's lots there's lots
oh my goodness let me in let me in bro
let me in ah here we go ooh now I've got
playing shotgun ammo as good as that gun
is I've got the ammo for this one hello
knock knock come on in share my stove oh
you're just gonna stay there well that's
fine - ice-blue there's a button up
there
vizor been boink ooh well howdy I don't
even have to kill these guys I just have
to get past them how about it yeah yeah
who's the crazy axe murderer now me huh
Oh [ __ ] hell oh [ __ ] you Oh
alright fine you get a bullet you get
many bullets right here ugly face okay
now I can just run past these guys in
through the gate
wherever the gate is ha no no I'm
cornered ah [ __ ] hell no I lost all
my health how did he get me twice okay
maybe I do have to take care of some of
these guys at least
secure that one the second probably axe
down let me ask you question
ah here don't don't bro don't do it
don't do it
YouTube you neither also- no you uh I
got you all oh oh yeah yeah you're oh
damn it got hit but it's to be expected
what I'm facing this many oh so bro oh
yeah
jump Oh bleep dodge yeah oh yeah oh so
bro one down
yeah do down yeah uh uh
why didn't I save ah ah
one down or not one hit not one down
not yet hmm got a hit on all yeah oh
yeah oh yeah awesome bro
Oh what's this Oh epically 360 ah you're
60 ax-chopped ah [ __ ] it
ha come on come on [ __ ]
yeah ah ah yeah yeah corners huh no not
yet don't got me hmm oh [ __ ] you oh come
on
ah come on why don't you go down one
down one down I think one down wind oh
[ __ ] I hit one of them must have come up
behind me I can do this I know I can do
this
ah [ __ ] how I can do this as I die
immediately okay dodge dodge two trees
first step is dodge the trees then dodge
the peeps you dafuq Oh what now where
did he come from
ah I can't see a bloody thing and I
don't want to waste all my well I I
guess I have plenty of batteries but you
know I don't want to use it ah [ __ ] I
haven't hit a single one ah right round
the trees also bro
ah why'd you crash down ah you're
quicker what the hell
what did that one get so quick oh what's
this oh no oh come on come on come on
you ugly
ah son of a-- hmm
yeah where's that other one there is
you're not gonna sneak up on me this
time oh yeah okay Ned combat save hmm
yeah I said huh
I see you ah where'd you come from
flying BAM boom yeah come on bring it
bring it
you stay there you want you don't even
wanna fight
oh yeah one down save yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah
or the third where the fourth one go to
down good combat save em Georgia where
the other one there was one more unless
I got him did I get him and not notice I
think I might have I see you anywhere
yes all with the axe hello buddy
you're getting next to me
yah oh you're super quick maybe I should
be more careful with this one
ow [ __ ] ah [ __ ] you [ __ ] that all
right just just I'll shoot him
easy-peasy I've got the ammo I should
start using it
plussing these close quarters ooh
this house looks bows that ah not a
spitter get suck some revolver ah ah man
that one's tough it's a tough monster
okay that's all my revolver it's locked
[ __ ] get me in here's Johnny
no okay let's be
here I push the button ah you
I can I can ask you I'm gonna ask you
down remember oh there got ya fat [ __ ]
just don't want to get cornered take
that few more up that was it yeah you're
dead okay
okay I'm gonna get in and did I push the
button that open this thought I did no
how the heck um
oh here we go there's a different area
here oh it's hard it's so hard to see
sometimes you see these parts are just
so similar oh [ __ ] hell ah I can't
take these guys straight on I can't
goose go straight back because they're
quick they're attacks or sometimes just
instant and then I take damage so
another one okay I hear another one
perfect flawless execution hello
I treat now [ __ ] hell oh hell on my
back here I thought I saved after that
one don't matter come here come here
mwah yeah mwah sometimes I can watch
other but most of time it takes two
what was that oh oh it's a big thing I'm
not that worried they just take a lot of
bullets oh my god it's a full clip there
we go one six forty oh not another one
screw you I'm just running past oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] distant Bucky like they said
[ __ ] you ah [ __ ] me ah I said [ __ ] Yoona
[ __ ] me oh this one
okay there's a guy wait how are you
there
ah that's what uh oh I'm so stupid
let me take care of those guys from a
distance I could aim for the head but
it's not like they all hit it okay
where's the other one c-czar
I barely see them okay I just gotta I'll
take care of this one
womp I don't know that shot does
anything on this monster gah
there we go six rounds sometimes looks
like that's a way out maybe I don't even
need these guys Oh breathe
can we wha
another spitter [ __ ] me oh come on die
guy what the hell how are you oh good
you got hit by your own friggin friendly
fire man ah the pain in the balls I got
to take this guy out
or maybe I can just get by some I could
probably dodge dodge I'm so pro ah so
pro there we go dodge dodge dodge dodge
gouging say even bohtan dare leave did I
get it I think I got it
I hear splishy-splashy ah ah why could
thank it in that older other building
that was over there I don't know I'm not
gonna ask too many questions about this
game not everything makes sense
well practic what oh okay well I was out
a revolver and ammo anyway so I didn't
even see it Desert Eagle there again
what the hell what there's like it was
an invisible something or other I don't
know what the deal was with that but
whatever crash I can't get in no no how
does owl anything on the ground II okay
it doesn't look like anything they're
running low on ammo again because
friggin part shock god damn it
ah
oh ah where are you where are you ah ah
damn it oh oh not another one
oh they're everywhere I guess is why
they gave me the desert eagle because
I'm gonna need it alright where'd you go
damn it
Oh what the hell yeah ah gap how can you
hit me not fair man was there another
one over here yes there is
Wow freaky frack okay I just gotta be ah
or I can miss missing is cool too
one shot Chuck one shot in there I'm
gonna wait like I know where he is
ah what what hit me
you're stupid blue not bees eyeballs ah
I don't even know me at least take one
down
I don't know where it is anymore huh
damn it oh damn it oh you're over there
ah I just got to take it out quick
oh no that's the other one it decided to
join the party
the party I said party ha ha ha oh oh oh
no all right anyway that's all the time
I got for this episode I'm gonna take
care of them later so thank you
everybody for watching and I will see
you in the next part
bye bye